SIERRA: Hello out there. This episode was
produced in conjunction with CFR's "Women in
Foreign Policy" program. They've been working for
years to elevate the status of women and girls,
and to make sure everyone is informed about
global issues related to gender equality. So,
please, after the episode, check out their
page at cfr.org. You can find a whole range
of really amazing work, and I encourage
you to do it. These include their Women's
Power Index and a new suite of content
about human trafficking. Okay, thanks!
TEEKAH: And
it's such a visceral foundational thing that you
just want to have a good life. That's it. You just
want to have a good life. And these are such basic
human rights that we're all entitled to. The right
to life, the right to be free from sexual assault,
the right to be free from torture and confinement,
the right to a sustainable livelihood, the right
to decent working conditions and to respect.
SIERRA: Human trafficking is more than
just a crime, it’s a process. A process
that slowly deprives people of their humanity by
exploiting what is most human in them. The process
is lucrative, and deeply ingrained in the global
economy. Experts estimate that there are between
25 and 40 million victims of human trafficking
globally, and some say it’s one of the fastest
growing aspects of transnational crime.
Today we’re going to talk about a segment
of human trafficking known as labor trafficking.
And our primary focus is going to be the United
States - because this crime is happening everyday
right here, in our own cities and neighborhoods.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and
this is Why It Matters. Today,
what is labor trafficking,
and how can it be stopped?
ANDOLE:
My name is Suzy Andole. So, when I was working in
Africa, I met a friend, uh, who is a nanny. So,
when she mentioned about the job, I'm like, “Oh,
yes I will go.” I [was] supposed to work Monday
to Friday to get $439 per week. God answered
my prayer, you know. I'm getting a better job,
better pay, for my better life, [for]
me and my daughter and my family.
SIERRA: Susy Andole is a survivor of
human trafficking. She came to the
United States to work for a Somalian
family that sponsored her visa.
ANDOLE: So, I went home, I came back to Nairobi,
they scheduled my flight. I came here in [the]
United States. You know I'm new. It was a
little cold. In my country it's not cold.
I didn't know, you know, we are staying in
the plane that long. My feet was all swell, you
know. I can't even fit in my shoe[s] and I was
wearing high heel[s] for 20 hours in the plane.
So, she came and pick me [up] at the airport.
So, from there she brought me home. I'm so
tired. So, after that, I ask for food. She gave
me something little. I'm like, "oh my God. This
is not enough." So, my life started like that.
SIERRA: The fact that her host family didn’t
feed her after a 20 hour flight was only
the first sign that promises made to Susy in
Kenya would not be kept in the United States.
ANDOLE: I used to work 14 to 16 hours, sometimes
18 hours. When I started, let's say in October,
November, I didn't get my salary. My first
salary was in December. Only $200. And she
told me I still owe her some money because I'm
not paying anything. Like, I'm living for free:
free food, free house, and I'm still paying the
[plane] ticket. She bought it for me to come over.
SIERRA: Her legal documents were also withheld,
and she was never allowed to
leave the house on her own.
ANDOLE: Things started changing. So, she
was telling me, "Oh, you can't keep money
in the house." That time I don't have even
ID. I don't have even any of my documents.
SIERRA: Wow.
ANDOLE: She used to tell me, "If you
run, I will call the police. They will
take you to jail. After jail, they will
deport you. I was stuck with no way out.
SIERRA: So what actually defines
a victim of human trafficking?
TEEKAH: So there are different
legal frameworks that we can use
when defining whether someone is a
victim of human trafficking or not.
My name is Anita Teekah. I'm the senior director
of the anti-trafficking program at Safe Horizon.
SIERRA: Safe Horizon is a leading victim
services nonprofit based in New York.
TEEKAH: But the most common that we use is the
federal trafficking victims protection act,
which means legally that you have
to be a victim of either the use of
force or fraud or coercion in order
to compel you to engage in any type
of commercial sexual activity
or any type of forced labor.
SIERRA: While sex trafficking is a regular fixture
on the evening news or Law and Order episodes,
labor trafficking can be harder to see. But it
is happening. One of the main misconceptions
about labor trafficking is that it’s mostly
about smuggling people across borders against
their will. And while that does happen,
it’s not the crux of the issue at all.
TEEKAH: By and large, the majority of our clients
who are subsequently trafficked as domestic
workers come here through the legal immigration
system on temporary nonimmigrant worker visas.
SIERRA: So they weren't being
trafficked at the time that
they entered the country or at
least they weren't aware of it.
TEEKAH: Correct. And so what it looks
like is usually in the home country,
a recruiter is acting on behalf of a family
or on behalf of a company and they are making
certain promises to interested applicants for
a domestic worker position. The recruiter will
note the hours of work, the work conditions, the
pay. And then when the worker comes over here,
they encounter a situation that's very different,
whether it's working 18 hours a day, and not being
given any breaks, not having adequate access to
food, not being allowed to take time off to see a
physician if they're experiencing any injuries or
complaints. And so the promises that are made in
the home country are often very different from the
reality encountered in the destination country.
LAGON: Trafficking sounds like it's about
movement, but it's really the human trade.
SIERRA: This is Mark Lagon. He served as the
Director of the Office to Monitor and Combat
Trafficking in Persons under President George
W. Bush, and was the Executive Director of the
Polaris Project, a global leader in the fight to
prevent modern-day slavery and human trafficking.
LAGON: So people will tell poor people in
developing countries, neighboring countries,
you can have this great job, this
great experience, a better life.
You can send money back to your
family. And if you come work here,
either as a guest worker with papers
or coming, undocumented, we'll get you
into a good job. And then they're lied to,
they're put into something really onerous,
nasty forced labor situation. And it turns out
to be the equivalent of modern day slavery.
SIERRA: And what are the recruiters or what are
these organizations getting in return for this?
LAGON: Money. I mean, the fact is that
it's worth thinking about the economics
of this. There are criminals, either small fry
criminals or big organizations and they choose
human trafficking over arms trade or, you
know, drug trafficking, because there's the
maximum payoff and money and the minimum
chance that they're going to get caught.
SIERRA: And who else is
benefiting from this process?
TEEKAH: Frankly, it's the family for whom
the domestic worker is working. If the
domestic worker's coming over here as part of
a scheme that's perpetrated by a large company,
like a nursing home company or a home health
aide company, then they're obtaining really
cheap labor from foreign countries. They
are targeting individuals who are already
so incredibly financially unstable. They
are getting an incredible amount of work
for free or for very low costs and the cost
that is paid by the worker is unfathomable.
SIERRA: So in some of these scenarios,
is the host family even aware that
their domestic worker is trafficked?
TEEKAH: So it depends on how that domestic
worker came into that person's household,
into the host families, sort of, orbit. And so
at times, yes that host family can know very
well that they are not giving this person breaks,
that they're not paying them their hourly rate,
that they're not providing them with overtime,
that they are not providing them with access
to food and to medical care, and even if
the worker was originally recruited by a
third party intermediary, once that person
is in your home, you have an ethical and a
moral obligation to ensure that you're treating
them like a decent human being. And, you know,
it's funny because I don't know that employers in
the United States think that critically about it.
I think what they see is this is a cheaper form of
labor. With private workers, if you pay the worker
under the table and so they're not declaring taxes
or if you're not paying your worker at all, you're
not likely to announce that publicly or document
that anywhere. So we actually don't know how many
privately employed domestic workers there are.
And so that's why it's so hard to estimate how
prevalent human trafficking actually is because
with the numbers we do have, it's incredibly
pervasive. And so we know that like with any
other type of crime that's severely underreported,
if we know of a thousand cases, there are
probably 10,000 cases that we don't know about.
SIERRA: While the exact numbers aren’t known,
the issue has received a lot of attention
from lawmakers over the last two decades. In
fact it’s been a rare case of bipartisanship
across several presidential administrations.
LAGON: In the year 2000, the Trafficking Victims
Protection Act was passed. I played a small part
as a Senate staffer. It was a wonderful example of
people on the left and the right coming together.
That doesn't happen very often today. And that
legislation helped set up an apparatus to hold
the perpetrators of human trafficking to account
- prosecution, to help the victims - protection,
and to try and stop it from happening
in the first place - prevention.
It also sets up provisions for the US
helping other countries by putting out a
report to give grades of other countries
and give them advice and assistance.
I used to head the State Department
office that that legislation created.
SIERRA: And how successful has it been?
LAGON: In the United States there's been a
lot of progress. It's varied in the 50 States,
more of the progress has been made on sex
trafficking. The international labor organization
and a lot of experts on human trafficking have
found that over three quarters of the victims of
human trafficking are exploited for labor rather
than exploited for sex. And so looking for those,
finding those people, protecting them, giving
them shelter, giving them medical care,
giving them therapy and helping them get trained
for other work to reclaim their dignity, those
labor trafficking victims, that's the frontline
of progress that we need to grapple with.
SIERRA: So, once someone's been identified
as a victim of human trafficking in the US,
what tools exist to help them at this point?
LAGON: Well, first of all, if they're from another
country and they happen to be undocumented,
but it's not their fault that they've been subject
to three words in the law and the UN treaty,
force, fraud and coercion. They have to
cooperate with law enforcement. If they talk
with law enforcement or an immigration official
and help share information about those who have
been exploiting them, they can be given what's
called a T visa, T for trafficking. And they can
stay in the United States on that humanitarian
visa. They can even work. And they should be,
because they should be treated, not as someone
to deport, but someone to help. A Congressman
at the time of the legislation, Lamar Smith was
so suspicious that people would lie and say they
were human trafficking victims, that he put a
cap on the number of those humanitarian visas.
SIERRA: What's the cap?
LAGON: The cap’s
5,000 and never gotten close to it. It’s a
reasonable thing to have been put out there to
reassure those skeptical about people who might
game the system. It hasn't proven to be needed.
SIERRA: Politicians of both parties have been
focused on human trafficking for decades,
but experts say that the current framework is
still not helping the majority of victims. Part
of the problem is that most victims
don’t understand their basic rights,
much less specific mechanisms
like T visas that could provide
them with a path to freedom.
SIERRA: What are the forces that
bind to someone in human trafficking? What
is it that keeps them stuck where they are?
LAGON: Intimidation and debt often. It is
often not the most desperately poor person,
but someone who is in a very difficult position
economically who is lured into, you know, teenage
prostitution or into migrant worker situations.
And then it turns out that in the process,
they have put themselves deeply into debt for the
privilege of being put into a horrible situation.
They're afraid of not only surviving
this situation of exploitation
but if they came forward, they'd
be blamed or sent home in shame.
SIERRA: Mark is talking about
something called “debt bondage”.
TEEKAH: Debt bondage is a form of human
trafficking. And so say for example, the host
family charges you $5000 for the plane ticket
and for the visa and for any other travel and
immigration related costs. You don't have $5,000.
And so we've had clients who have leveraged or
sold ancestral land in their home countries. They
have sold everything they can. And they've also
secured loans, not only from local banks and
lenders, but also from external and extended
circles of families and friends. And so now you
have this debt. Now you're told by your employer,
okay, you have to pay $500 a month for housing.
You have to pay for any food that you consume.
Couple that with either not being paid at all
or being paid very, very little, there is no
way you are ever going to pay off this debt. So
many of our clients have expressed incredibly
deep feelings of shame, and remorse, and guilt.
Because if you've borrowed money from family and
from friends, all of those individuals have a
financial and an emotional stake in your success
in the United States. It's an incredibly shameful
thing to have to admit to all of these people who
have invested in you, people who couldn't really
afford to invest in you, that you in some sense
have failed. And we know that it's not a failure.
We know that they're actually victims of crime and
exploitation, but that's not how they perceive
themselves. They perceive themselves as gullible
or naive. And so they continue to stay in the
situation with the hopes of making some money
back so they can send some money back to their
families or back to their home country to start
paying down this debt. And so in addition to the,
the emotional sort of bondage and the debt bondage
it's also confiscating passports and documents.
If you don't have any of your identity documents,
if you are kept under lock and key and you cannot
leave the house, if you don't speak the language,
who are you going to talk to? So we've had
clients who've been trafficked from state
to state and they don't even know what state
they're in. They don't know what city they're in,
they don't know what resources are available
to them. You're operating completely blind.
And given what is covered in media around
the world with respect to the US immigration
system and our deportation scheme, it's not
unreasonable that a foreign national domestic
worker would have a really tangible, credible
fear of being deported by an abusive employer.
SIERRA: In telling her story, Susy cited
all of these fears. And another one, too.
ANDOLE: I wanted to run, to escape,
but we have this young little girl.
She wasn't even a year yet. So, if I look
back, I'm a mother. I have my own kid too.
If you leave the house, who you're
going to leave the kids with?
All that hour in the house. Then when I'm
leaving, I'm running, I'm going where?
SIERRA:
Right.
ANDOLE:
They will
still catch me where I am because
you don't know where you're landing,
you know. I will go run and go out there.
That person will report me to police.
SIERRA: Her first chance at any type of freedom
in the United States came when she
asked to attend religious services.
ANDOLE: I told them, "Oh, I need to start going
off. I want to go to church." I'm a Christian,
they were Muslim. She took me
to a church, a Lutheran church.
When I went to that church, those church
members were so friendly. They were happy
to see me. They were all white, I was the black
one in that church. So, they come to talk to me.
Where are you from? I told them I'm from Kenya
and then one mentioned, "Oh, there's another
lady from Tanzania." I told her, "Yes, uh, I
don't have my ATM card, I don't have my ID,
I don't have my passport. She's keeping all my
things." And the woman said, "That's abuse."
SIERRA: Susy had found a friend, someone
who started explaining her rights,
and who soon found her additional
work in nearby New Rochelle. But
this initial moment of hope turned out to be
the first in a chain of new working abuses.
Susy was eventually able to escape her first
employer. And yet afterwards she found herself
in a series of homes where person after
person exploited her vulnerability. She
eventually landed in the Bronx. There, someone
overheard her being abused by her latest employer.
ANDOLE: She's yelling at me in our
language and this guy was American,
he sensed something the way she was talking to
me. Like, “uh, do faster, do quickly.” So, in the
elevator he ask[ed] me, "Oh, uh, who are you to
them? Are you related?" I just started explaining
to him. He's like, "Oh, I have a big house. You
can come and clean." And then my first question
was that, "Are you going to pay me?" He say
like, "Yes. I will pay you $20 per hour." I was
so happy. And then I went there, but I'm coughing,
I'm sneezing, I'm so skinny, like you know. I’m,
my face, even if you look at me, you just
know right away she's going through something.
So, he told me, "Oh, I can't even let you
clean my house. You need to go to the doctor."
So, when I went to Montefiore Hospital,
I filled [out] the form. I didn't put the
address. Why? Because they told me
to not give their address anywhere.
So, when my doctor call me and then he say,
"Miss Andole, uh, where do you live?" I
didn't want to give the address. So, he
looked at me and then he tell the lady,
we came with one lady from African Services who
took us to the hospital. He told him to go out.
So, he told me, "Miss Andole, do you have any
problem? I want you to tell me and I won't tell
anybody. I want to see if I'm going to help you."
So, I started telling him I'm from Kenya. I came
here to work, uh, with a diplomat as a nanny.
Since I came to this country, if I get sick,
I've been given Advil and Aleve. If I go to my
menstruation, I don't have even sanitary diaper. I
used to use my t-shirt. I started opening for him
because he told me he won't mention it to anybody.
SIERRA: Right.
ANDOLE: And then he said, "That's
abuse. Let me call Safe Horizon."
SIERRA: Susy visited Safe Horizon’s
Anti-Trafficking Program. There,
she was finally in the hands of professionals
who could give her the help she needed.
ANDOLE: So, the case worker ended up
calling me. When I went to the office,
like on the waiting room, when I saw her
coming. Like, the love she showed me,
like I feel like, this is
it now. This is, you know.
SIERRA: Yeah.
ANDOLE: I cried, she hugged me. I cried, I cried.
I wasn't crying because I'm in, uh... because
of the stress and what I'm going through. I was
like, now, I've found my sister. Like I find now,
she is going to give me help, you know? She told
me, "Don't worry. We'll try our best to help you."
SIERRA:
Do you think that the system as it currently
exists is helping the majority of victims?
LAGON: I wouldn't say that's helping the majority
of victims, it's helping more and more. One of the
problems I must say, is the lack of good data.
It's clear since that legislation was passed
20 years ago, that we've made great progress in
laws, finding more victims. But my sense is that
there are many more out there who have been
victimized that are afraid to come forward.
SIERRA: I mean, there's a lot of fear
in the idea of being in a situation
where you have no power and then going
to let's say the police and trusting
that they will help you in the right
way when you actually don't even know,
let's say about a T visa or any of the
rights that you have in this country.
LAGON: Yeah. And the exploiters reinforce
the notion, you can't come forward,
you're going to be blamed, you're going to
be treated like the criminal. And, and they
have a lot of trauma. They're subjected
to violence and intimidation and fraud.
And one of the things when you find a human
trafficking survivor is you need to remember
not just shelter, not just physical
medical care, but deal with the trauma.
SIERRA: So, how are we finding
and prosecuting the perpetrators?
LAGON: Well, take for instance a maid who is
confined to a home, beaten, she might flee
and then she might talk, to law enforcement or
immigration officials about, those she worked for,
those who mistreated her, the recruiters back
in her home country, those who placed her in
the United States. And then law enforcement has
evidence. This one of the reasons why having a
heart and helping the human trafficking victims
is not just, you know, kind of a, a do-good
social welfare policy, but it will help them be
one of the most valuable sources of evidence.
SIERRA: What is the international
community doing together?
LAGON: Good question. The international
community cooperates on trying to look at
patterns of human trafficking. Those
who are illicitly recruiting people,
the money flows. Countries are given advice by
the UN office on drugs and crime and the United
States on how they can form better laws and much
more importantly how to implement those laws.
But we need to increase the intensity. Countries
notice. Wow, the United States is in our face
about this and offering us help on this. It
doesn't help their business interests. And
this is what we should be building and restoring
our foreign policy around. A calling card for
America that has a heart, that shows that we will
use power to stop something truly destructive.
SIERRA: What are your thoughts on how the current
administration is handling human trafficking?
LAGON: I think there’s some very good
things going on in this era. There's a
lot of interest in human trafficking at the
White House. The daughter of the president,
Ivanka Trump has shed light on it. I think the
president has, perhaps perverted the understanding
of human trafficking by suggesting that those
who are trying to smuggle people across the
border are human traffickers and the answer is
higher walls. The answer to human trafficking is
not to think of the problem as people's movement
across borders. It's to look at the exploitation.
SIERRA: There's been a lot of talk
for years about needing, you know,
comprehensive immigration reform.
What is the relation between our
overall immigration policy and
the issue of human trafficking?
LAGON: At the time the human trafficking
legislation was passed in 2000 and for the
most part since then, there was an understanding
that human trafficking victims needed to be
differentiated from the general issue of
people being undocumented. I think I myself
feel that there needs to be some sort of policy
of regularizing the status of those people who've
been here for years. We need to think about the
children of those who came to the United States,
undocumented, those people who do decent work.
I think the first step towards really reducing,
the flow of, you know, elicit migrants is
to deal with the situation of those who
have been here for a while. But separate from
that, we need to maintain that understanding
that there are those who come to the United
States either as documented guest workers or,
undocumented, who are subject to force, fraud and
coercion. And they lose control of their life,
and they need to be treated like they're
fellow human beings like you and me.
SIERRA: Mm-hmm.
It's kind of a, you know, low bar baseline ask
just to be treated like a fellow human being.
LAGON: You know, I'm a Christian, uh, I, you know,
I believe all people are of equal value. They're
all, you know, formed in the image of the Lord.
People who are secular, uh, look to UN treaties,
see the, you know, universal,
equal worth of people. Same idea.
SIERRA: Do you think that this is a problem that's
just too big for the United States to solve?
LAGON: There is no reason to think that
globalization automatically leads to there
needing to be slavery. It really isn't necessary.
And the cost of doing more to assist victims of
human trafficking, beef up law enforcement,
give technical assistance to other countries
so they not only passed laws, but, improve
them, and implement them, that isn't all
that expensive. Look, when I headed the human
trafficking office of the State Department,
we had $18 million to give to all countries in the
world to nonprofits or international agencies to
try and help victims of human trafficking
and train people to fight the problem.
When we spend billions of dollars for corporate
welfare, uh, for defense, which we need for
our country, for important economic relief for
our citizens, merely doubling that 18 million,
would be nothing. It's in our means to
put a real dent in this problem and to
be able to study whether the things
we're doing are making a difference.
TEEKAH: Honestly, it comes down to love of
family. And people will do anything for the
people that they care about. I have seen some of
our clients put up with some of the most horrific
sustained abuse for the possibility of making a
hundred dollars in a month that they can send to
their family so their child in Mexico or in Peru
or in the Philippines can go to school and get an
education and not have to do what their parent
is doing. And the tipping point for our clients
is when I'm making no more money, I'm not making
anything whatsoever and I continue to accrue this
debt that I can't ever pay off, I have to do
whatever I can to leave. We've had clients who
have just run out the front door, they had nothing
with them. They couldn't take their clothes,
they didn't have their passport, they had
nothing. And they just tried to find their
way to the nearest police station. Or they would
talk to somebody at church and they would say,
"Help me. This is what I'm going
through. Can you please get me out?"
SIERRA: Wow. That is incredible. That must
take just an unbelievable amount of
bravery to do something like that.
TEEKAH: It does. And you know, it
doesn't end when the person is out
of their trafficking. That's honestly, that's
just the beginning of the rebuilding for them.
ANDOLE: It wasn't [an] easy journey, but
I'm so happy where I am now. I'm still
with them. They help me. I have a green
card, they help me bring my daughter here.
SIERRA: Wow.
ANDOLE: To reunite with me. Now even
I can talk [about] it without crying
because through the help I get from Safe
Horizon. They bring [a] smile on my face.
SIERRA: With proper help, Susy was able
to get out of trafficking and into a
home where she has built a new life.
She has remained with Safe Horizon,
and is working to help
those who are still trapped.
SIERRA: I mean, when you were trapped,
did you know that you could go to the U.S.
authorities and tell them that you were a
victim of human trafficking? Did you
know there were laws to protect you?
ANDOLE: No, I didn't know because, why? How will
I know? Even if I know, you're going where? I
was new in this country. This was my first time
traveling, going far from my country. And it's
not me alone. We have a lot of people going
through a lot and I was lucky they didn't,
like the man didn't rape me. Some they rape
them, some they do such a bad things to people
and people are shy. Like people are scared,
if I say, if I run, and then you look back,
even if you do this, where are you going? You're
going to maybe kill yourself, commit suicide. So,
you're like, "Let me stay in this position
I am." You know? So, to me I would like,
like if there's a way, these things have
to be on TV every day for people to learn.
People are going through hell out there, but
they don't, they don't know their rights.
SIERRA: If you believe you have information
about a case of human trafficking,
or want to connect to human
trafficking services in your
area, please call the national human
trafficking hotline at 1-888-373-7888.
Be sure to subscribe to Why It Matters
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher,
or wherever you get your audio. And if
you like the show, leave us a review!
Interested in saying hi to the Why It Matters
team? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by
Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is Markus
Zakaria and our assistant producer is Rafaela
Siewert. Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri
Torjussen. Special thanks for this
episode go to Richard Haass, Jeff Reinke,
Anita Teekah and the team at Safe Horizon,
and our very own Rafaela Siewert, who truly
led the charge on this very important episode.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you next time!